threads a new social media that is
already banned in Europe collects a ton
of your personal information including
your race and ethnicity sexual
orientation biometric data Trade union
membership pregnancy status politics and
religious beliefs data about your
employment details about your health
Fitness your browsing history web page
interactions photos videos and location
information more than 100 million people
have already registered and the goal is
one billion and the funny part is that
all this data can be sent to a third
party yup Zuckerberg probably knows more
about you than your own mother so what
do you think tried it already follow
some sub to know more about privacy